[Musique]
chez julliard un nouveau roman de pierre
boulle docteur du pont de la rivière
kwaï la planète des singes c'est un
roman qu'on pourrait appeler un roman
presque d'anticipation peut-être qui
sait mon roman de science fiction
on pourrait aussi l'appeler un conte
philosophique à ce n'est pas un roman
réaliste d'un roman qui part d'une
hypothèse parfaitement fantaisiste mais
assez fructueuse pour un romancier en
tout cas pour un compteur l'hypothèse
est la suivante la planète dont il
s'agît la planète des singes c'est une
planète où les singes occupe la
situation qu occupe sur notre planète à
nous les hommes et ou inversement les
hommes occupent la place que tiennent
sur notre planète à nous les singes dont
on imagine à partir de ce qu'ils potez
toutes les fantaisies qu'un romancier et
romancier satirique sur tout comme les
pierres bull peut utiliser imaginé il ya
toutes les situations humaines sur notre
planète trouvent leurs correspondants
chez les singes il ya des singes de
lettres des singes du monde des singes
de science de danse est à peu près 7 à
pierre boulez par les nobles desseins de
bonne volonté des dizaines de voisins
l'égalité est une satire est une satire
de non pas des singes bien sûr mais de
l'homme c'est une satire
poser cette question je me suis posé à
moi même en mon âme et conscience je
crois effectivement que la réponse oui
il ya une certaine partie c'est terrible
je crois quand vous avez eu cette idée
est venue de doux comme en lien avec la
vie dans la rue qui vous ne pouvez
penser qu'il pourrait y avoir des
échanges à la place des yeux plusieurs
choses et plusieurs spectacles je crois
qu'il vienne plusieurs observations
il est en particulier l'observation des
singes est aussi l'observation des
hommes dans quelle situation par exemple
dans beaucoup de situations des singes
peut enfin je parle des grands singes
des dessins des entreprises n'est pas si
vous avez jamais vu un singe dans un
gorille ou une orang-outan dans un zoo
c'est un spectacle absolument
extraordinaire sur les façons sur des
singes les hommes je veux dire dans
quelles situations précises vous avez vu
des hommes et ça vous avez pensé que ça
pourrait être décevante beaucoup de
situations dont beaucoup de
manifestations en particulier une dont
j'ai parlé dans mon livre il s'agit
d'une visite à la bourse
c'est un exemple je crois effectivement
c'est une chose qui m'avait frappé je
crois je prends vraiment une sincérité
que nous mettre de bon sens qui n'est
pas prévenu en avance et qui se trouve
transporté à la bourse à la bourse paris
par exemple ne peut pas imaginer une
seconde que les aides qu'il a sous les
yeux sont des homo sapiens ne peut pas
imaginer qu'ils agissent par raison ce
n'est pas possible de dire qu'ils sont
conditionnés
oui absolument que tous leurs attaques
sont des réflexes conditionnés que leur
comportement est un comportement animal
ou l'intelligence n'a aucune part je
vous ai cité la bourse pourrait citer
bien d'autres sont beaucoup de
manifestations collectives
c'est une impression qui m'a très
souvent qui menait après souvent qui
s'est imposé oui en particulier gens se
parlent on livre aussi certaines
réunions politiques certains procès les
réactions des acteurs si vous voulez
aussi bien des avocats que des juges des
procureurs la même chose ne m'ont paru
relevé à aucun degré de l'intelligence
mais pas du tout où défendre et d'avoir
faire les deux sciences fiction tout
même à nos populations sinon davantage
méprise pas du tout la science fiction
je crois même que ce n'est pas
exactement en cela une science fiction
général s'est passé au second plan
l'humain alors que mes personnages sont
tout à fait humain la planète la peintre
que je décris ressemble tout à fait part
à terre et les personnages mois que ce
sont des singes c'est entendu mais ils
ont des réflexes humains comme vous
disiez tout à l'heure c'est qu'il ya des
singes du monde des singes de lettres
des singes de six ans et c'est de ce
point de vue là je ne crois pas qu'on
puisse dire que c'est en science fiction
[Musique]